[Musik]
manchmal widerfährt einem im leben
derart schreckliches dass man nicht
darüber reden sondern nur in dunklen
farben davon machen kann
heute ist christina cloozy 45 und ihre
bilder werden immer fabinger das ist
glückliches baby das zweitälteste kind
vor sind bin ich auf vox in bolivien in
südamerika und meine hand spielen
übersetzt und hat als missionare
geschaffen ich bin ganz natürlich im
urwald aufgewachsen ohne irgendwelche
oder fernseher oder irgend ein bisschen
und ich bin lustig sieht ganztag für
busse aber leider ist das glückliche
sind nicht immer glücklich sie bezieht
[Musik]
ja dass der steuerpflichtige warum ich
das so gemacht haben aber mit
sächsischem in die hölle los gabe da bin
ich von verschiedenen anderen bis 11 xi
bin vergewaltigt wurde von verschiedenen
und das regelmäßig sie hat das alles im
namen gottes gemacht und ich habe keine
andere wahl funde zum in rees electric
geht schmale ist die einzige was sie für
mich zum reden und sie darf nicht wieder
sich im gefängnis es ist aber sie rät
trotzdem
sie malt einfach sie war nicht das
einzige opfer
aber das wusste sie damals noch nicht da
zum beispiel das ist also ist er noch
bin ich ihnen geschmissen wurde oder
innen komplett honig 67 und dann bin ich
vergewaltigt wurde von meiner mama ich
mag mich auch die vergewaltigungen über
erinnere mich sehr schnell macht ich
wollte bin aber er hat mich noch aus
neid und die frau begann zwischen dem
konsum in körperich kukksi ich schon
innerlich bin ich zerriss xi und
schwächt verwundet und das ist im loch
ihnen passiert genau ist deutsch und ich
fertig das passiert nicht nur einmal
unter und merkt es und immer wieder und
dann kommt der nächste missbrauchen und
dann wirklich wieder geschosse zum
nächsten und die eine schön einen noch
im anderen das ist brutal stieg sie
fallen
er hat mich als erste mit sexy trocknung
und der also ist stück wald bis zu
wirklich bewusstlosigkeit für die sind
also dass er noch knapp überlebt aber
ganz ganz brutaler jetzt oft dazu
geklagt
das jetzt sehr viel trockener täter hat
ausgesagt dass war mir irgendwie besagt
dass sie werden mir sehr gestört ist
eine glaube die niemals glauben und dann
wird ihn foto dies müsse ins heim zürich
schweiz und dann wird er auch nämlich
eine bibel übersetzte und alle indianer
paketiert ölen und ich habe gewusst im
prinzip hilfe ich mein vater bibel
übersetzte wenn ich erhebe und ruhig bin
und dann ist nicht noch den garten und
in dialogen titel und ich bin schuld und
mit den schultern ich nicht kenne und
ich bin 60 sie das haben wir gerechnet
und immer und immer und immer wieder
zeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe meinem alter versucht zu
erzählen mit 16 jahren ist klar und
deutlich gesagt es ist schlimm steht mir
passiert wohl jedem eigentlich auch
passieren und es kann es wirklich sein
wird das weiß ich nur und für sie ich
das einfach gar nicht und rocco das ist
paradies auf erden für sie und sie haben
mir hat jetzt beste jemals im kg und der
irischen iaws schlimmes passiert danach
verstummte sie wieder bis sie mitte 30
war bis zum tag ihres zusammenbruchs und
ein wenig romantik oder nämlich schwarz
worte und ich liebe sie und gehört und
wo nicht wieder verwahrt bin eigentlich
chrysler braucht man nicht wichtig
machen immer gut jetzt ist es passiert
wo messlatte für andere wird und kann
christ innerlich ist ein kampf
losgegangen
jetzt muss ich sage was ich jetzt
untersucht es laut sie einfach nimmer
abdrucken
[Musik]
so fing sie an zu erzählen zuerst nur
ihre freundin gudrun hier am rhein wo es
ein bisschen wie im urwald ist redete
sie stundenlang nach dem langen
schweigen brach es richtiggehend aus ihr
heraus leider vollkatastrophe das erste
fehler ist extrem
sie hatten das gefühl dass jetzt endlich
mal klar redet und ich habe fast nicht
verstanden weil es einfach dominant war
bis ich kapiert haben dass sie wirklich
hundertfach missbraucht wurde ist und
mir bitte vor dem zelt und wie vor dem
und plötzlich vor dem nach und nach
konnte ich das dann bisschen
strukturieren und sagen fragen komplett
selber noch mal was ist dort wirklich
erinnern von anfang an dass es mir in
einem rutsch mal erzählen also also das
war wirklich nicht leicht das war sehr
emotional aber ich habe ihr glaubt will
jetzt einfach clever wie der bilder
das waren wir ganz klar dass da viel
viel dran ist wo mit der ordnung ist
gudrun hörte lange zu und begann alles
aufzuschreiben
irgendwann kam die idee ein buch aus
christinas geschichte zu machen was du
erlebt hast also auf deutsch türke ganze
scheiß sondern es geht darum zu zeigen
man kann sich aus dem herausarbeiten
also egal was einem im leben passiert
ist es gibt der lösung man findet den
weg man kann wieder sich geburts leben
aufbauen
also das war mir ganz wichtig dass das
schon mut machen das buch ist und
andererseits zum schutz vor wind dass
man einfach dieses tabu brechen kann
dass darüber geredet wird wütend angst
um über missbrauch treten
die familie war nicht glücklich über die
veröffentlichung aber ihre jüngste
schwester sarah steht hinter kristina
sie ist erst in der schweiz geboren und
blieb von den missbräuchen verschont
sarah getraute sich nicht die eltern in
christinas erste lesung einzuladen
auf dem missionsstation sind alle ein
tolles gleiche ziel sie während alle
bibel übersetzte und will alle dankbar
wir sind ja alles richter hat mir mit
irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise dank dass
eine elitäre gruppe könnte sie
ordentlich gedanken das vertrauen ist
einfach uncool groß sie und es werden
sie in sinkt das vertrauen in der frage
und so ist es möglich sie das mit ihrer
zeichnungen mit husten mit ecosia machen
wäre der schule mit musik das mädchen
nicht so interpretiert hat wie sie
möglichkeit sie sind und nicht gemerkt
hat dass das mit dem missbrauch
ja das ist sehr schwierig sie als ist
für mich schwierig sie das überhaupt
erzählen will das ist ein guter freund
von ihm vortrag sie das gemacht hat der
meine eltern sind einfach kurz mal
zusammenbrüche und dann gesagt dass sie
ihre tochter ist mit ihrer tochter
chopins passiert unter ihrer nase und
sie haben das nicht gemerkt und grüne
darauf reagieren um für sie ist der
totale zusammenbruch uns verhalten ist
es extrem schwierig gemacht die die
ersten paar jahre sind einfach eine
gewisse erzählen sie hat nicht wie
reagieren
das ist es hin und her das ist ihr land
sie wirklich
christina krisis eltern sind nach wie
vor in einer freikirche aktiv in diesem
film wollen sie selber keine stellung
nehmen
aber sie verfassten ein schriftliches
statement es tut uns zutiefst leid dass
unsere tochter in ihrer kindheit in
bolivien sexuell missbraucht wurde und
dass wir das bemerkt haben als sie uns
vor zehn jahren über den missbrauch
informiert worden wir am boden zerstört
zwischen christinas erinnerungen und
unseren eigenen bestehen unterschiede
wir haben uns jedoch entschlossen dies
nicht an der öffentlichkeit aus zu
diskutieren denn dies würde mir offene
fragen schaffen aus antworten geben und
sich belastend auf die beziehung
zwischen unsere tochter und uns
auswirken kann ein understatement die
heidestadt drehen dass ich nicht
schrieben dass jesus mich kalt hat ein
kinderbuch statik statements reizend
einfach bis aufs blut oder dass ich
genau das falsche für das opfer es freut
mich nicht was ich will oder braucht es
gab einfach nur für unsere familie ist
es äußerst schmerzhaft natürlich ist es
für sie auch schmerzhaft aber sie könnte
das andere und sagen wir stellen leider
hinter mir unterstützen die moralisch
mit harfe die mit dem tag hoffen dass es
gut gegangen
ich bin's opfer ich bin jetzt nicht mehr
und jetzt sind sie sofort am sitz ist
bleibe ich komme zurück ich gerne zurück
dass ihnen ihre eltern übersetzten
damals im auftrag der internationalen
organisationen recall von sar die bibel
diese organisationen schicken noch heute
christliche mitarbeitende in abgelegene
gebiete als die ersten opfer zum ersten
mal redeten untersuchten weekly von shl
die missbrauchsfälle in den eigenen
reihen und mussten erkennen sie hatten
pädophile mitarbeiter die die opfer
sagen dass es sehr sehr leid tut was
dort passiert ist
es ist lange her aber wunder wo das
geschlagen hat die sind tief und
schmerzhaft ist in der schüler dass das
hier ist eine reise passiert ist vor ort
seien aber persönlich keine tun ich nur
christina kruse conti vorstandes
christina kritik weil tag mit dem buch
das sie das endlich mal
es gibt aus speck wurde ich sagen muss
ich finde es gut was das hat und ich
merke auch im gespräch mit mir zu machen
das schon noch einiges an arbeit die
empirie vor sexuellen übergriff
vorhanden ist und das buch das 13
dass man darüber reden dass wir gut und
30 missionars kinder liebten auf der
station in den siebziger jahren damals
war sie zur miss brauch kein thema
das nutzten die täter schamlos aus
dass gott noch braucht wird zu wenig in
der anstiege also es wirklich eine
katastrophe das zeigt wie pervers typ
sie sind das du an gott sie ist wo das
alles mitgewirkt hat und mit über hat
das löst wie mir sehr viel fragen muss
um ihre koffer antwortet der ältere von
christina kruse ländern artikel
schrieben ihre häftlinge mit dem titel
dennoch und das muss ich ja sagen denn
noch mit infrarot an
dennoch bin ich mit gott unterwegs oder
die schüler denn wir haben fest aber es
sind fragen wo wohnen kann während
stören die frage
christina kruse war sie alleine mit
vielen unbeantworteten fragen und verlor
den glauben an diesen gott der sie nicht
beschützt es war ein langer
schmerzhafter prozess
bis sie wieder ein erfülltes leben hatte
auch in der sexualität
ich habe panik ich habe mal ich überlebt
die hochzeit nicht dass ich nachher
wieder bezirk zu meiner musik und ich
bin ja auch rechtlich aufbruchs also 36
wurde irgendwann das nicht so oder und
und ich habe mich entschieden das
komitee das ist mir sofort die
sexualität das gehört einfach dazu
andere hand spaß darum die not und und
dass man die mir versucht raketen ein
um dann bin ich so verrückt worden und
hat doppelt und ich weiß nur ich kann
grün auf dem weg dass man mich nicht
selten tragen
das hole ich mir zurück nicht ein
millimeter lang nicht mehr für biker und
da bin ich nun zehn xii oder 20 und ich
habe mir heimlich den wirbel kommt und
dann alles ausprobiert mit mir selber
und hand wisst das schaffe ich jetzt
wieder und dann habe ich auch gelernt
sagen was ich will
sie erkämpfte sich zwar eine unbelastete
sexualität
trotzdem schaffte sie es in den dreizehn
ehejahren nicht ihrem mann von den
missbräuchen ihrer frühen kindheit zu
erzählen
zu groß war die schar als ihr start ging
die beziehung in die brüche
mitte 30 war sie plötzlich
alleinerziehende mutter von zwei buben
ja wohl nicht dann die tradition dass
angriff über und über mit 312 die
honigbiene denn so ganz verblüffend
erklärt dass mit mir nicht gut
geschossen und dass ich das jetzt muss
verarbeiten und immer wieder digitalen
ich muss brüderle
die beiden söhne sind heute 23 und 21
jahre alt und seit zehn jahren ist
christina glücklich verheiratet mit
roland ihm hat sie die ganze geschichte
gleich am anfang erzählt die freundinnen
der söhne gehören inzwischen auch zur
familie mit verarbeiteten tonnen einfach
wie sie hilft halt so viel heiterkeit
und es ist schwierig zum sich das
vorstellen aber mir hat es für wirklich
dass die person schmerz vielleicht wenn
man noch irgendwie oder und das ist eine
person das ist heftig
wo sie eigentlich so was ist schon
einfach sehe ich will
nachdem es gestern den aufzug sie dass
sie
die nachher kriegen wir in ihren mega
rock wissen was sie da man ja noch mal
sagen was wirklich da wolle
das ist ein comeback für uns beide das
ist so meinen wir die andere opfer kann
dass sie absolut diesen haben sie das
geschafft hat braucht für seine krise
hat es fast geschafft sich von den
geistern ihrer kindheit zu befreien
nur ein mosaiksteinchen fehlt ihr noch
im heilungsprozess eine rückkehr nach
bolivien mission im retro oder der
kollege und weiter verzögern das ist
megaschön dass woche ging es eigentlich
ich glaube nicht das ist wirklich für
mich das paradies wird ich glaube ich an
abschlüssen mit
die von den missionaren missbrauchten
kinder leben heute vor allem in europa
und in den usa
christina kruse will sich mit einem von
ihnen treffen und zwar dort wo alles
passiert ist in bolivien auf der
damaligen missionsstation in dommitzsch
[Musik]
seit 30 jahren war sie nicht mehr dort
da greifen
[Musik]
ihr ehemaliger spielkamerad erwartet sie
in ribera
ariel kommt aus norwegen
er lebte drei jahre auf der
missionsstation und hat auch erst vor
ein paar jahren zaghaft angefangen über
die missbräuche in seiner kindheit zu
reden
im gegensatz zu christina war er schon
mehrmals wieder in die spur
[Musik]
unglaublich ich träume nicht meinte
sektor irgendwie möglich
ich bin froh dass ich fühle mich auf dem
tisch die sich genauso wenig im buch gar
nicht mehr sagen china habe am nächsten
tag fahren sie nach dem super
was wird dort passieren was denkst du
ich weiß es nicht
was wird nicht dort hatten ich denke wir
gehen einfach mal die hauptstrasse
durchs dorf
dann siehst du die wichtigsten gebäude
die internationale schule schon mal
siehst du das die verkaufen hier ein
jaguar feld
[Musik]
solche trophäen gab es überall zu kaufen
als sie kinder waren die beiden
ehemaligen dschungel kinder sind
natürlich fasziniert
[Musik]
ein
lasst uns gehen
[Musik]
wir sind fast da
ich bin so nervös hier werden wir den
kleinen fluss überqueren erinnerst du
dich damals gab es keine brücke wir
mussten mit einer fähre rüber jetzt ist
trockenzeit der fluss ist in der
regenzeit viel höher als jetzt
schau mal auf den turks hat die ganze
familie platz
ich glaube ich schaff das nicht ändern
du kannst das
das muss kurz halten wenn du willst
lasst uns langsam machen
das ist eines der ursprünglichen häuser
ein bisschen langsamer fahren bitte das
sind die ursprünglichen häusern auch die
da hinten wirst du gleich die schule
sehen
hier ist die schule ja ich bin völlig
überrollt und überrumpelt und es ist so
ambivalent schön und glich so falsch ist
was koche und dann aber was die blondine
dann die erinnerung an die schöne ist
auch für mich mit denen mit denen
schrecklicher bin ich ruhig halten
diese bäume gab es schon und das ist die
kirche
ich erinnere mich an diesen raum dort
links du weißt wer dort oben liegt er
kann ich da hoch gehen kann
ich glaube dass benutzen sie als kirche
[Applaus]
jetzt muss ich noch nie
erinnerst du dich an diese räumen und
wie ich mich erinnere
das ist erstaunlich das zedernholz hier
silbe fußboden
[Musik]
er drückte meinem kopf runter während
ich vor ihm zwischen seinen gespreizten
beinen saß und ihn mit dem mund
befriedigen musste
es dauerte lange und mein ganzer kiefer
tat mir weh bis er endlich zufrieden war
so ging das woche für woche und ich
haben ist doch nix da hat er sie nicht
um krieg und dann rufen oder gemeint die
starke sich viel länger da sage ich mir
ich muss der überstunden und nach
die soziale kontrolle ist an einem
solchen ort doch relativ hoch stellt man
sich vor
es hat niemand gesagt es hat einfach
nichts beruhigt ich bin untergang wir
sind eigentlich umgegangen
es ist einfach viel wichtiger sie das
typische sätze wo die dauer machen und
die orte zu machen und mir sind einfach
untergegangen
wir sind einfach dort auf vor allem
einen teil von und euch gott so gut er
hat schließlich paradiso fährt um pasta
genauso ich eigentlich sagen ich bin
doch sie die kontrolle des foto nasa und
und unter der familie hat man gemacht
was man will
[Musik]
da bin ich als letztes mal trocken mal
die transfer mieter aber ich habe es
nicht geschafft und bin da ist steigend
und wenn wir nicht dahin ändert und das
hat die schnitte dauer das ist immer da
und bin brutal drachen und das ist ein
ort ohne schnee wieder wett betraten
ich hoffe dass die menschen glauben aber
ich komme wieder
sie war elf als ihre eltern mit ihr und
den drei geschwistern in die schweiz
zurückkehrte während 30 jahren lebten
hier missionars familien aus aller welt
jeweils zwischen 100 und 300 personen
[Musik]
das ist nicht nötig
da ist auch an die amokläufe und da hat
das loch kommt bist du und ich möchte da
ist irgendwas kaufen wir sind immer noch
kuchen ein so will der mieter ist ein
junge mein junge schöne übersetzung sind
da hat euch so furchtbar faul und der
halter einer übersetzt mit dem vater war
im büro konkret ist noch nicht alles
ich hatte das ist 1 70 sie glauben und
da inhaltlich sonst wenn da eine musik
häufig haben ja alles gut unter noch
nicht ganz heimlich da ihnen das
[Musik]
die verlassenen missions- häuser übergab
der staat damals den einheimischen die
jungen wissen kaum mehr etwas von den
missionaren die einmal hier gewirkt
haben aber bei den eltern dorfbewohnern
gibt es plötzlich an wiedererkennen
[Applaus]
anna war damals aber nachbarin und
erinnert sich an die kleine christina
sie erzählt dass marta die
hausangestellte von familie crew sie
kürzlich gestorben ist
ob die einheimischen damals etwas von
den vorfällen in mission dort
mitbekommen haben das bleibt im vagen
[Musik]
ariel macht sich auch auf spurensuche
dieses haus war ein kinderheim marias
eltern arbeiteten auf einer anderen
missionsstation ironie der geschichte
sie schickten ihn hierher weil die
schule einen guten ruf hatte es ist
immer noch so wie damals
[Musik]
10 11 12
in diesen drei jahren
es war ein wunderbarer ort für häuser
wir durften schwimmen fischen
wir hatten viel spaß ja man kann es
nicht bestreiten es war ein wundervolles
leben in verschiedenster beziehung aber
es ist traurig einige von uns verließen
diesen ort mit wirklich schlimmen
erfahrungen was haben sie ihnen angetan
ich vermute ich habe dinge gesehen die
an zehnjährigen nicht sehen sollte waren
die schwierig zu erklären sind
die ein trauma auslösten in der
dunkelheit passierten
ich erinnere mich an eine szenerie
draußen ist es dunkel
menschen mit abgedeckten gesichtern
vermutlich erwachsen ich bin nicht
sicher ist eine art grab feuer solche
angst machen in sachen die mich all die
jahre verfolgten
[Musik]
ich habe auch erinnerungen an drogen
erfahrungen die wir nicht wollten
[Musik]
sie gaben uns irgendwelche drogen
ich habe sehr bizarre fast theatralische
dinge gesehen die sehr schwierig zu
erklären sind aber große ängste
auslösten
[Musik]
über den eigenen sexuellen missbrauch
kann er vor der kamera nicht reden
[Musik]
so wie er mussten auch christina kruse
und andere kinder an okkulten ritualen
teilnehmen
sie erinnern sich an viele bizarre
verhaltensweisen der erwachsenen
darum möchte christina unbedingt etwas
erledigen bevor sie die kuba verlassen
die beiden beschließen in der nacht auf
den friedhof zu gehen obwohl oder gerade
weil sie furchtbare erinnerungen an
diesen ort haben einige monate vor
meinem zehnten geburtstag ging ich mit
meiner familie zum abendgottesdienst auf
dem weg dorthin rief jemand meinen namen
und man führte mich direkt zum friedhof
im dunkeln konnte ich einen jungen
erkennen zwar ariel auch andere kinder
waren dort ein mann sagte du bist der
welt so gut hin
auf einem baumstrunk lagern rät loses
kind und kerzenschein tristan messer auf
dann bildet dann die männer einen kreis
um das kind wird ein murmeln und an
flüstern
ein mann gab mir eine schale trinkt
befahl er
ich musste einen brechreiz unterdrücken
als ich merkte dass es blut war ihr als
auserwählte habe das echte abendmahl
getrunken niemand darf es wissen sonst
geht es euch mit diesem kind und andere
werden euer blut trinken
[Musik]
bis vorne geht mir dann befiel
ich habe dieses kleine bolivianische
herz hier und ich möchte es hier
irgendwo begraben
es ist okay wenn ich das jetzt machen
ja
hier ich habe ein messer
[Musik]
kleines baby es tut mir leid dass ich
dir nicht helfen konnte
bei
ok
[Musik]
muss man davon ausgehen dass hier im
urwald weit weg von der zivilisation
hilfe sind und christlicher alltag so
nahe beisammen lagen verschiedene kinder
erinnern sich an solche rituale
warum waren diese seltsamen vorfälle bei
den erwachsenen nie ein thema heute 40
jahre später tummeln sich immer noch
kinder am see wie damals christina und
ariel
die beiden tragen noch die narben von
damals innerlich wie äußerlich die
männer haben ihr als sie sechs jahre alt
war mit messern in die knie geschnitten
bis vor kurzem zeigte christina
niemandem ihre namen nicht einmal ihre
eigenen kinder durften ihre knie
berühren zeichnen als das das müde zu
erklären und das mit rosel welt sind für
was kann ich für mich dass wir den
stampf luft sterben
hier laufen alle cloud award for sme
klimaschädlich zwei schnitt und also dir
was wissen gesehen
ja es ist eine schlimme ort zum telefon
das ist noch etwas macht was der woche
sein wand und die augen streue ich das
machen was wir witzig schnitt oder ich
weiß nicht was passiert ist das nicht
beschrieben was ich nicht will
um menschen gewinnen
[Applaus]
ariel war dabei als die mädchen markiert
wurden
ich denke ich sah die runden
ich habe erinnerungen an die frischen
schnitte in den knien
das war etwas vom ersten worüber ich mit
den mädchen geredet und sie gefragt
haben auch andere dinge ich kann nicht
mehr sagen wann es passiert
ich wusste einfach dass sie geschnitten
worden waren
[Musik]
ernsthafte okkulte rituale waren
das habe ich mich immer wieder gefragt
oder es einfach etwas womit die typen
spaß hatten und sie dabei zu weit gingen
ich weiß es wirklich nicht aber
natürlich die symbolik war die von
okkulten praktiken
[Musik]
ich habe nicht mehr gefragt weshalb ich
mich daran erinnere und warum ich nicht
geschnitten wurde
es blieb immer ein mysterium
ich glaube niemand kann eine logische
begründung geben für dieses verhalten
uns bleibt nur darüber zu spekulieren
leider
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
viele fragen bleiben unbeantwortet in
the jar zurück
die antworten wissen nur die täter die
opfer waren mindestens 17 kinder welche
die schrecklichen erfahrungen und bilder
bis heute in sich tragen
die reise nach bolivien war eine
emotionale berg- und talfahrt für
christina krise ein wichtiger schritt
auf dem weg zur heilung
ich kann jetzt alles wohl in der nacht
statt gemacht also ich kann mich an mich
verabschiedet ich kann den normalen
genug ich bin noch mal zurück gegangen
kam ich noch mal konfrontiert nacht auf
dem werk zusammen mit dem orden
ich habe meine angst überwunden ich bin
normal luft standen und wie sich alles
haben bis zum schluss und das eine dass
eine so dass stimmen oder ist und hingen
38 und immer im kopf wieder rund und ja
damit hab ich ja nie maxi und der
geniale von überwunden wurde
auf dem rückweg in die schweiz ist sie
in miami eigentlich mit einem
amerikanischen jugendfreund aus dem jura
verabredet seine eltern leiteten damals
die missionsstation er ist journalist
und will in den usa diese geschichte
publik machen
aber er sagt ihr kurzfristig mit einem
male ab wir gehen jetzt sich dann zeigen
aber er hat angst dass sie die eltern
dass er seine eltern könnten machen
es ist extrem tief besprüht und angst
dass familie kommt dass die bank
entweder mit identitäten und so blieb
genau wie politiker genau genauso
[Musik]
die täter wurden bis heute nicht vor
gericht gestellt
weil wir wissen dass sie in ihren reihen
pädophile mitarbeiter hatten haben sie
inzwischen einen kinderschutz
beauftragten eingestellt
[Gelächter]
er habe mit allen tätern gesprochen
einige haben sich entschuldigt und wir
haben das als teil des heilungsprozesses
für die opfer gesehen
einige täter waren tot als wir sie
befragen brücken und andere stritten
alles ab und sagten wir wissen nichts
von alldem sie bestritten alles von
anfang bis ende und es hat nicht die
möglichkeit den tätern den prozess zu
machen
das können nur die gerichte das heißt im
klartext die betroffenen hätten die
täter damals selber anzeigen müssen und
das ritual mit dem leblosen kind
wäre es nicht aufgabe von wolf und sar
gewesen
auch dieser sache nachzugehen
es warten
wenn das wirklich passiert ist dann wäre
es total grauenvoll
aber im moment haben wir keine
übereinstimmenden aussagen darüber dass
es wirklich geschehen ist ist es nicht
beweis genug dass mehrere kinder von
damals übereinstimmende erinnerungen
haben die betroffenen haben sich an den
von sel organisierten heilungs
seminarien erstmals wieder getroffen
für die opfer ist es sehr wichtig sich
immer wieder über das erlebte
auszutauschen
und sie wollen sich nicht mit der
antwort von es sei er zufrieden geben
dieser mann war zur gleichen zeit in
bolivien wie christina auch ihn hatten
die missionare auserwählt ihm geht es
nicht so gut wie christina mit seiner
familie hatte beispielsweise bis heute
nicht über den missbrauch geredet und
die wort woher nimmt die tiefe stau
nichtige mir das herz wenn er sagt das
ist das ist mir diese für die
tiefenschärfe und ja in der hand für
geschafft dann kommt mir das richtig ein
kapitel so ist das christkind
kirchen machen christina kruse heute
misstrauisch in volkertshausen in
süddeutschland gibt es in der kirche
keine predigten mehr sondern
ausschließlich kultur
schon mehrmals hat sie ihre bilder hier
ausgestellt
[Musik]
ihre tante und ihr onkel kommen an jede
ausstellung
sie waren zwar keine missionare lebten
aber mit ihrer familie damals auch in
bolivien ohne von christinas leid etwas
mitzubekommen und man hat